[Music]
zach is with us in oklahoma city hey
zach how are you
i am
doing all right i guess
okay cool how can we help
uh
well this is where the i guess part
comes in it looks like about a 90 chance
that i'm gonna end up divorced here soon
and i'm
trying to figure uh hoping uh dr john
can help with some advice on how to just
kind of stay focused because this is
screwing with me a little bit and i'm
not doing performing well at work and
stuff
so are you are you asking about
the okay so back me out here you said
about 90
and then i got sidetracked here so
i'm assuming you're not into this this
isn't your idea
nope
okay so what happened
um
uh the short version is that she
struggles with borderline personality
disorder and does not believe that she
needs help and she has just started
making a bunch of ridiculous impulse
decisions and then
blaming me for the fact that nothing is
working out and that we can't afford the
marriage counseling and stuff that we
need and she just finally dipped out
okay
so
um you say there's 10 chance that this
isn't going to happen is that a
realistic percentage or is that you just
hanging on to hope
the latter okay has is there attorneys
involved yet has she filed on you
she's not filed anything
if i'm being truthful i bet that if this
goes through i'll probably end up having
to pay for it when i finally get sick of
waiting and just decide to move on
myself but
all right so in this situation here's
the person you can deal with you
and i can hear the bitterness dripping
from your language which i don't i don't
i don't blame you i'd be bitter too i'd
be frustrated and sad and upset and all
that
but that is clouding all of your
judgment all of your decisions all the
words that come out of your mouth all
the thoughts in your head your inability
to get up and go for a walk or a run in
the morning your work performance
everything
okay
so
you tell me you can't afford to go talk
to somebody i'm telling you you can't
afford not to
figure it out
okay
call some friends or call a pastor call
i'm not talking about her i'm talking
about you
okay
this isn't about her right now this is
about you you can't control what she's
doing and she stepped out on you okay
do you hear what i'm saying
yeah i know what you mean and i
apologize if i started through this that
happens when i get frustrated with
situations like okay
what i was trying to say is like she is
she was the reckless spender in our
relationship i kept trying to wiggle
between trying to budget for all the
help that we needed while trying to keep
her happy with the impulse purposes she
wanted to make and
i'm gonna go see somebody because it
sounds kind of bad but now that she's
walked out i can afford to do so because
i have to spend on her recklessly hold
on hold on hold on i just told you
stop talking about her and you
immediately came back and started
blaming her for other stuff
i'm
sorry no don't be sorry i'm just just
listen to how much this has poisoned
your heart
okay
and the only thing on planet earth you
can control
is your thoughts and your actions and
that's it
and that is
a powerless helpless feeling in these
moments when someone you love has said i
don't love you anymore i'm out of here
it's heartbreaking it's devastating
and yet the only thing you can control
is your thoughts and your actions so i'd
make a phone call today and say i'm not
okay
every minute of my life is venom and
poison towards my wife she's leaving me
and i'm not okay anymore and i'm using
anger and rage and all these other tools
to try to prop myself up through this
heartbreak and i need to look somebody
in the eye and say i'm not okay
that's what i mean
and so
the language that you used like when we
started talking about the um
you can afford counseling you circled
back and said well now that she's out of
the way
you see what i'm doing instead of just
going yeah i've actually got the money
now
there's two different sets of language
saying the exact same thing
and uh but that's just due to the that's
just your pain you can we can hear the
pain in your word choices
and even in your voice tone
um and so and that's what's throwing you
because
i'm gonna guess john that uh
if i were in this situation i know what
i would be doing uh if i were losing
focus it would be because all i'm doing
is replaying all of these tapes in my
head over and over and i should have
said and what if i'd have done this and
i could have done that and then if she'd
done that and i'd said that and uh all
these ruminations all these things
you're never really going to do these
conversations you plan out they're never
going to happen that's right and you
ruminate on them and play on them and
play on them and play on them and play
on them and play on them and all of a
sudden the car's driving down the
shoulder instead of the middle of the
road that's exactly right and you hear
the warning track and you go wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
i'm not even driving
and so zach
real quick now that dave mentioned it i
forgot one of the main reasons why i
wanted to call and ask about this i
drive a truck for a living i'm alone for
three to four weeks at a time
okay that's part of why i think this
anger has caused me problems the way i
realized
yeah that makes sense and and
i know enough about bipolar that a gap
missing another person
can be devastating to that so i bet if
she was to call she might be saying hey
i've been
missing my husband
for months at a time for years over year
over year and why do i tell you that
most of the time in these situations
unless there's just an out-of-control
abuse situation
more everybody's playing a role and so
this vitriol this anger this rage all
you're doing is poisoning yourself
hoping she it rubs off on her and it's
not it's killing you
so breathe it out man stop having these
imaginary conversations with her and go
talk to somebody and if you can't afford
a counselor because people are listening
and going i can't be nice find a couple
of friends it goes back to that it
demands a witness your heartbreak and
your grief and your sadness you got to
have other people you can say hey i'm
not okay with
and i don't need your advice i need you
just to say man i'm so sorry i'll get
the next round yeah as far as the money
thing goes until you get through this
process you're probably not going to
make any traction
on your finances
because um you know it's expensive
it's distracting and so you're in the
middle of a hurricane and when you're in
the middle of a hurricane you don't work
the total money makeover baby steps yeah
you push pause and you pile up cash to
get through the hurricane then when the
hurricane goes by
and it's over then we assess the damage
and we start rebuilding from there we
push play again we start working the
baby steps and that's how you're going
to do that as far as your finances go